I'd like to tell about another side of
him you know much of his writing is
rooted in what he called spirituality
which is I guess the best english
english translation that we could come
up with about this deeper dimension its
existential dimension beyond just a
psychic and the biological and dr.
Franco had a deeply spiritual side and
it was both religious and not religious
he did not believe of course that
religion had a place in psychiatry that
that was up to the individual patient
and we we neither use that as a solution
Nora criticized it as Freud did as just
an underdeveloped sense of something he
respected it and believe that it could
help those that could help but it was
not the psychiatrist roller the
psychologist role to be able to impose
that on people and he really was
insistent on the differentiation and in
his own life as I said earlier he was
not particularly observant religious or
Jew but he was a very spiritual in his
beliefs beyond the dimension of man he
said you either have faith that you
don't it's nothing you can prove it's
nothing you can query and if you believe
you believe and he believed however he
had another dimension to the
spirituality that I think very few
people knew about one day I was driving
from Baltimore to Washington because he
was giving a speech for approximately
3,000 people at the washington hebrew
congregation and he had called me to let
me know he was coming in and asked if i
could pick me up the airport those kinds
of things which i always did and I
because there's always a lot of traffic
and I live about an hour from Washington
I left very early and got there about 20
minutes early and when I arrived I went
up to the hotel room and went to knocked
on the door le opens the door and she
goes like this I walk in very quietly
and in a cornered room facing east is
dr. Frankel with a set of tefillin Owen
and he's quietly obviously praying I had
never seen who do this before and I
spent a lot of time with him many many
Saturdays etc which is a Jewish Sabbath
I'd never seen him do that kind of thing
before I know he had strong Jewish
identity was very proud of his Judaism
and but I'd never seen him do anything
like that before so I we very quietly as
quite as I can be asked him about it on
the way to the thing and and he told me
a story he said that at the end of the
war they were death marching the
concentration camp inmates and
condensing them into various camps and
then they would destroy the old camps
and there's no evidence of war crimes
and in the last camp he was in I'm not
sure this time I think it was Turk i'm
i'm not sure near Dachau and they had
marched him into the camp but there were
different inmates from various camps now
and one day one morning he gets up and
he looked server and someone had
smuggled in a set of tefillin the Jewish
prayer boxes that Orthodox Jews use when
they do their morning and evening
prayers during a week and he saw this
man get up and say the prayers and put
them to fill in and when he was done dr.
Franco asked the man if he could borrow
his tefillin to put them on he just had
an urge to do this and he said I hadn't
put on tefillin since my bar mitzvah
when I learned how to do it but I just
felt like I want to do it and he asked
the man he had to kind of remind him how
to put it on and he put it on and he
said he couldn't he was so weak he
couldn't remember any Jewish prayers so
the only thing he could remember was the
cottage which is a prayer that affirms
the importance of life at a time when
people die people commonly refer to as a
prayer for the dead but it's really a
very life-affirming prayer and it's the
only thing but I'll Jews nor this prayer
and he's only thing he could remember by
heart so he got up put on tefillin that
day and said cottage well if you talk
about divine intervention that afternoon
the camp was liberated by american
soldiers and he told me that for the
rest of his life he got up every morning
put on tefillin and said Coty's so that
was the kind of spirituality beyond just
really
jessore or observant that he possessed
and I had never known that and I was
very private part of his life I'm almost
afraid to private to tell but it was
such a fascinating part of him and in
fact many years later when he was
getting old now you have to remember us
getting old I didn't meet him till he
was over 70 it was about 71 I'm sorry
Beth 71 when I first met him and I never
thought I used to say to you I wish I'd
met him when he was 50 because you know
how old am i how long will i get to know
him of course he lived to be 92 and it
was wonderful but many years later when
he was getting older we had a
conversation one day my family in
baltimore's in the funeral home business
where the jewish funeral director in
baltimore and he was always fascinated
by this because he always had to
concerns about his death one was that he
couldn't be buried next to le because in
cemeteries in Europe you're buried in
religious sections and you don't bury
Catholics with Jews in the United States
we have many non-sectarian cemeteries
and he found that very interesting in
fact my understanding was that at one
time he even looked into whether there
were any in Austria and there weren't
not any and then he sort of came to this
realization that it didn't matter
whether he was buried next to her not
she would always be in his heart so he
that was interesting him but the other
thing was that because his family his
daughter and his grandchildren are
Catholic it always bothered him that he
didn't have a son who would say Kaddish
for him because it's a tradition in
Jewish life for a child to say cottage
on the anniversary of the parents death
and it's a very important tradition I
always do it for my father and
grandfather and and he was talking to me
and I said well I always do it for my
father and my grandfather because it was
important to them my grandmother wasn't
so important to so I didn't do it my
mother of course is still living so one
day he said to me would you say cutters
for me if the right guy
and I was so moved that he saw me as a
son or that close that of course I
agreed immediately into this day I
always go to synagogue on September
second and I say Kaddish and usually
within a day or two I call Ellie to tell
her that I've done that and I know he
has one other person to do it for him
also rabbi bulk I believe in Canada who
was getting older now and I just thought
that was that was my most touching
things most important things he ever
said to me because it was really a true
confirmation of what I always felt about
him but that I didn't dare think that he
would feel about me
you